muchas gracias muy buenos dias andrés
buenas tardes lo que nos dice es la alta
fragmentación que tienen los partidos
políticos acá en el país estos partidos
políticos no nada hacen de la nada nacen
prácticamente de la fragmentación que ha
tenido otras fuerzas electorales
nacionales especialmente las de corte
conservador liberal en donde
prácticamente hay una digamos
sobreoferta de estas organizaciones
mientras que en el sector más estatista
y más progresista hay una menor cantidad
de fuerza relativamente señora ya según
las más recientes encuestas el número de
votantes indecisos incremento en
comparación con los comicios de hace
cuatro años a qué se debe esto tiene que
ver con los con el número de candidatos
y definitivamente tiene que ver con la
candidatura ya hay una tendencia en
costa rica que efectivamente a que el
abstencionismo haya crecido y crezca
continuamente de proceso electoral el
proceso electoral sin embargo el hecho
de que existan 25 candidaturas en un
estudio de opinión pública que se hizo
por parte de la universidad de costa
rica hace dos o tres meses se indicaba
que más del 66 por ciento de la
población consideraba que no se sentía
representada por la cantidad de fuerzas
políticas en este proceso electoral y el
44 por ciento consideraba que incluso le
gustaría que fueran mucho menos esto
significa que efectivamente la oferta
electoral no está de acuerdo con que
haya ya digamos hay mucha cantidad pero
no así calidad de partidos políticos
ahora cuáles son los principales retos
que enfrentará el nuevo mandatario como
llega el país a estos comicios
el país llega con una crisis fiscal
importante luego de también haber sido
agravada con el circular con toda la
pandemia y demás común por lo que se ha
llamado acá el apagón educativo que es
sensiblemente por mucho el problema
principal del país adicionalmente un
problema muy serio de
desempleo que afecta prácticamente ya a
pública torce 15% de la ciudadanía con
este escenario lo que nos lo que a lo
que nos enfrentamos es un gobierno que
efectivamente va a quedar electo en una
primera ronda cualquiera de los dos que
logren pasar para el balotaje van a
tener prácticamente menos de un 20 por
ciento del apoyo popular va a llegar con
una asamblea legislativa bastante
fragmentada no tanto en términos de
partidos sino de intereses y
probablemente también con una asamblea
legislativa en contra y no hay ningún
aspecto que haga pensar que la próxima
administración cuente con un apoyo
popular o con un apoyo a la asamblea
legislativa que le permita el bombardeo
de maniobra para llevar a cabo sus
propuestas así que tendremos un gobierno
clemente también popular en este momento